heute waschen wir wäsche bei uns im
haushalt haben wir alle aufgaben gut
verteilt janosch spült und saugt
ich putze und masche die wäsche das ist
unsere waschmaschine
sie steht im badezimmer wir haben glück
und haben einen waschmaschinen anschluss
in der wohnung
manche leute haben keinen anschluss in
der wohnung und müssen zum waschen in
den keller gehen in diesem behälter
sammeln wir die dreckige wäsche wie hast
du noch räche ich weiß jetzt ja nun
springt seine wäsche und steckt sie in
die waschmaschine
als nächstes tue ich waschmittel und
weichspüler in die waschmaschine dann
stelle ich die waschmaschine an
mit den verschiedenen programmen kenne
ich nicht überhaupt nicht aus ich wasche
alles bei 40 oder 60 grad
das ist unser wäscheständer hier hängen
wir die wäsche auch manchmal wenn ich
schnell weg muss bitte ich ja noch die
wäsche aufzuhängen
dann komme ich manchmal nach hause
organisch hat die wäsche in der ganzen
wohnung verteilt nur nicht auf dem
wäscheständer
er hatte nämlich keine lust jedes
kleidungsstück genauso aufzuhängen das
alles auf den wäscheständer passt nach
socken auf dem fernseher
warum warum das war unsere easy german
episode für heute jetzt sammle ich die
wäsche wieder ein und bringen sie zurück
auf den wäscheständer in der
zwischenzeit könnt ihr ein patriot von
easy german werden und uns dabei helfen
neue videos zu drehen
außerdem könnt ihr uns abonnieren damit
ihr keine videos mehr verpasst
hier könnt ihr uns unterstützen hier
könnt ihr uns abonnieren
tschüss und bis zur nächsten woche